même les enfants m'appellent vêti ces
lignes on me demande toujours appelé ne
pas pas aussi oui ils ont toujours ils
nous ont toujours appelé roger betty est
ce que betty c'est votre vrai prénom une
simple se donner c'est un diminutif
d'elisabeth qui est mon prénom mais on
ne m'a jamais appelé autrement que betty
d'accord toujours appelé betty que aussi
loin que je me souvienne les parents
m'appeler betis est resté tout le monde
que ce soit à l'école que ce soit mes
élèves que ce soit au bureau on a
toujours appelé betty mannequin à la
réunion chanteuse de variété et de
folklore betty ebrard a été l'une des
figures illustres du monde artistique
locale de ses parents elle à se cultiver
puis transmettre à l'eau si le sens de
la musique et du rythme
une passion encore intacte aujourd'hui
pour cet informaticien de métier
puisqu'elle enseigne désormais la danse
et produit des spectacles avec une
histoire c'est une époque pas si
lointaine qu'elle nous fait partager
depuis quand vous évoluez dans le monde
artistique ça remonte quand même loin
parce que j'avais 11 ans la dernière
fois je la fais la première fois je me
souviens 7 étant une sorte de spectacle
conte organisée
dans le cadre des fêtes de noël et on
m'a demandé de chanter avec
un monsieur qui jouait de la guitare et
on chantait l'homme et l'enfant
à l'époque c'était dit constantine une
petite fille qui chantait et je faisais
l'enfant le fait d'être la fille d'un
personnage célèbre à la réunion est ce
que ça vous a aidé quelque part dans
votre évolution
ce qui m'a aidé c'est le fait que aussi
bien mon père que ma mère était dans le
domaine de la musique de la danse parce
que danser tous les deux très bien ça
m'a aidé ou dans ce sens mais sans ça
mon père n'a pas cherché à me pousser ou
à me freiner d'ailleurs non je pensais
que c'était une suite logique que je
fasse de la musique de la chanson de la
danse comme départ ou est-ce que vous
vous transmettez cette passion en vos
enfants oui parce que les deux vies
chantent dansent comme moi il y en a une
qui a fait beaucoup de mannequinat dans
l'île un épi qui maintenant me remplace
dans le groupe folklorique c'est l'aîné
et la seconde sandrine qui chante dans
le groupe sont qui a été également
mannequin aussi bien sur le plan local
que à paris et qui maintenant chante
également
j'ai commencé à chanter uniquement du
brésilien parce que j'ai toujours été
fasciné par la musique brésilienne et
j'ai commencé avec ça tout mon
répertoire était uniquement brésilien et
après ça a été de la variété et la
variété ça a été beaucoup en très très
grande partie nicole croisille
en tant que chanteuse puisque je
chantais j'ai très souvent fait la
première partie d'artistes qui venait à
la réunion pour se produire
et quels souvenirs vous avez 2 c
très bon souvenir parce qu
automatiquement on est on est en contact
avec eux c'est un peu un ami qu'on croit
inaccessible lorsqu'on est dans une île
et puis finalement quand on les côtoie
ce sont des gens comme nous vous avez eu
l'occasion d'exercer votre passion ça
des scènes métropolitaine raconté devant
un petit peu comment ça s'est passé
alors beaucoup moins souvent sur la
scène métropolitaine parce que bien que
j'ai vécu toute mon enfance et mon
adolescence en france je suis ici
pratiquement depuis l'âge de 20 ans et
après j'ai vécu ici je me suis mariée
ici j'ai vécu ici et sur les salles
métropolitaine et étrangère puisque je
chantais avec le conte folklorique et on
a chanté un peu partout ça s'est produit
lors de voyages ou lors de tournées avec
le groupe folklorique parce que les
chansons qui vous a marqué le plus non
en fait y en a plein mais il y en a une
effectivement parce que
elle est là elle a un passé je trouve
qu'il est superbe parce que c'est c'est
benoîte boulard qui avait lancé ce
ségala l'époque et le sait qu'à piquer
et que j'ai rechanter mois ensuite avec
le groupe folklorique qui est sur le cd
du concours hippique vous arrive de
sortir quand même ça m'arrive encore
bébé ça ne vous manque pas trop simple
ça me manque un peu parce que j'aurai
presque voulu en faire mon métier c'est
un désir caché
qu'est ce qui vous a arrêté est bien
c'est que je pouvais je pense ne pas
pouvoir faire carrière à la réunion donc
j'ai préféré faire d'autres choses qui
me plaisait tout autant un tailleur mais
qu'est ce qui ne m'empêche pas d'artiste
donc bien il va complètement à
l'extérieur et quels cas je trouve que
c'est plus un artiste local
c'est beaucoup plus difficile il faut se
battre et bon c'est pas tout le monde
qui réussit forcément où on marche sur
les deux plans et ça peut marcher c'est
le tas de certaines personnes comme
jacqueline farreyrol mais entièrement
ici je pense que c'est dû est-ce que
vous filles viennent régulièrement
prendre conseil avec vous on se voit
régulièrement prendre conseil demain
j'espère que dans mon éducation de toute
façon j'ai essayé de dès lors de leur
donner l'essentiel cet inculte et dès
l'enfance
dès l'enfance déjà lorsque j'étais
enceinte de deux j'ai continué la
chanson donc elles ont appris la musique
dans mon autre parce que vos parents ont
été sévères avec vous mes parents tcv
par sega nous et j'ai fait la même chose
que mes filles c'est à dire qu'à
l'époque je trouvais pas ça bien du tout
quand j'étais enfant
mais après
je les ai remerciés parce que je me suis
rendu compte que ça m'avait beaucoup
servi papa et non c'est pas tellement
maman était plus sévère que papa je
pense mais papa était très juste
il était rigoureux juste mais pas
forcément sévère les monsieur auguste de
groupe qui est votre père ne vous a pas
inculqué cette envie de faire la
politique
il n'a pas poussé en tout cas il en
parlait à la maison il n'en parlait très
souvent parce qu'en fait lui il y en a
toujours fait mais moi personnellement
je suis pas très politique est-ce qu'il
avait une de vie ce qu'il s'est passé
dans sa famille
je crois que ça a été ce que j'ai fait
moi avec mes enfants c'était la rigueur
et patrick drevet avec soi même et avec
les autres
rooney sur vinyle donc en vase clos et
il est très difficile d'évoluer parce
qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas les mutations
nécessaires pour aller et pour faire
mieux pour aller au dessus pour faire
mieux j'étais dans le même cas lorsque
je faisais du sport
j'ai été numéro 1 et pour faire pour
rester à la tête ça a été très dur parce
que j'avais personne ou tout du moins à
m mais le tennis je suivais les très
tard et j'ai grimpé très vite en fait et
gp championne de la réunion de 79 85 80
hectares étaient complètement
vous avez stx et ailleurs mais plus
particulièrement dans la danse dans la
danse c'est une suite logique à votre
carrière d'artiste je sais pas si on
peut parler de suite parce que j'ai
toujours dansé
c'est vrai j'ai toujours dansé mais je
n'en sais n'y est pas alors que
maintenant je conseille et c'est qu'elle
chante dans ce que nous enseigne dans
une société c'est à dire vrai ce tango
paso cha cha samba toutes ses enfants
quand est ce que vous avez trouvé le
temps pour vous former alors je me suis
formée en fait en métropole et en
travaillant ici puisque pour passer les
examens je ne pouvais pas le faire ici
c'est pas possible ça ne pouvait se
faire qu'en métropole j'ai passé mes
examens avec la fédération française des
sports de danses et ça se fait sur deux
ans j'étais en métropole donc à
plusieurs reprises pour le préparer pour
préparer mes examens je les ai travaillé
ici et je les ai pas c'est finalement en
métropole vous êtes heureux oui est ce
que vous faites une différence entre la
danse et la chanson je fais la
différence dans l'expression elle même
mais pas dans la c'est un art de toute
façon et pour moi l'art ça se rejoint
d'une façon ou d'une autre
est ce qu'on peut dire que la danse
complète tout trafic tout à fait
faire
en dehors de mes cours j'organise des
stages je fais venir un professeur
d'afrique du sud
régulièrement la réunion pour organiser
des stages il ya un suivi
comme je vous dis jamais bon quand même
beaucoup de temps parce que c'est très
difficile d'expliquer aux autres ce
qu'on aime
si on aime c'est pas très difficile
certains apprennent plus difficilement
que d'autres mais lorsque vous voyez les
progrès et l'assiduité de certains à
vouloir apprendre c'est la récompense
professeur très motivés
c'est très difficile de choisir les gens
pour le spectacle n'importe qui à la
limite peut faire un spectacle à partir
du moment où il est motivé où il a envie
de le faire dans mon prochain spectacle
là j'ai aussi bien des élèves qui ont
quatre années de danse qu'un élève qui a
commencé cette année seulement il est
motivé il veut le faire et il apprend un
peu plus difficilement parce que les
autres savent de quoi je parle et lui il
est en train d'apprendre
donc il sait pas toujours de quoi je
parle
mais il apprend ils avancent plus
difficilement plus doucement mais il
avance et c'est super qu'il y ait ces
deux niveaux ou c3 où ces quatre niveaux
là ensemble
qu'est ce que vous pensez des nouvelles
musiques laura etc lorsque j'entends ce
que fait le groupe atp l'as moi j'aime
beaucoup
mélange le rap avec le maloya je trouve
ça super c'est l'évolution
il faut tout les choses évoluer le que
le folklore qu'on garde tout ce qui a
été notre folklore c'est bien mais qu'il
ait voulu c'est aussi bien
maintenant il ya simplement commune
donne et tu recevras c'est tout c'est
l'idée qui passe avant d'enfoncer j'ai
quelque chose à donner je vais le donner
avec beaucoup d'amour et ça passera tout
seul à partir du moment où il ya de
l'amour ça passe tout seul